1066 CE.
The English Throne sits vacant after the King
dies without an heir.
Three claimants to the title quickly rise,
and prepare to do battle over who would wear
the crown.
At the end of this turbulent year, invasions
would be mounted, battles would be fought,
and only one man would be left standing with
the prize grasped in his bloody fist.
It is a tale that reads easier as fiction
than fact, and in fact has been the inspiration
for many famous fictional dynastic struggles,
including Game of Thrones.
This is the story of the victor of this struggle,
who conquered a kingdom and changed the fate
of a country and a continent.
This is the story of William the Conqueror.
Early Life
Our story begins around 1000 CE.
Viking raiders have been terrorizing the coasts
of Europe for over 200 years.
They took vast tracts of land by conquest,
including the north coast of France by the
English Channel, which eventually became known
as the Duchy of Normandy.
Further advances came on the British Isles,
most notably in 1013, when the King of Denmark
conquered England, and Danes ruled the country
for 30 years before being driven out by the
native Anglo-Saxons.
In these early feudal times, the central government,
controlled by the King, was weak and decentralized,
the land broken up into a series of earldoms,
duchies, and baronies, ruled by an Earl, Duke,
or Baron.
These provincial leaders were, in theory,
vassals of the King, and sworn to him by an
oath of fealty, but in practice, they were
very much autonomous, and struggles between
the King and the provinces, and between the
provinces themselves, were common.
William was born around 1028 CE, the illegitimate
son of Robert I, Duke of Normandy.
This led to his original nickname, usually
used by his enemies: William the Bastard.
His father seemed to have little interest
in marrying any of his mistresses, which meant
that William was considered the heir to the
duchy from a very young age.
In 1035, Robert embarked on a pilgrimage to
Jerusalem, against the advice of his advisors.
He made it to the holy city, but fell ill
and died on the return journey, leaving William,
at age 7, the Duke of Normandy.
As was typical when a child inherited a province
or kingdom, there was great instability in
Normandy as the region's nobles and William’s
relatives fought each other for control of
the region and of the young Duke.
A series of William’s guardians were killed,
including one, Osbern, in the Duke’s bedchamber
while he slept.
Things came to a head in 1047, when Guy of
Burgundy rose in rebellion against the ducal
government, supported by other nobles.
They attempted to capture Duke William at
Valognes, had they succeeded, he almost certainly
would have been killed.
But William escaped and fled south to Paris,
seeking refuge with King Henry I. William
soon returned, however, at the head of an
army, and together with the forces of King
Henry, they defeated the rebels at the Battle
of Val-es-Dunes.
At age 18, Duke William was already showing
himself to be a capable soldier and commander.
The rebellion of 1047 was not to be the end
of Normandy’s internal strife.
William continued to deal with rebellious
nobles until 1054.
At this point, alarmed by the consolidation
of power under William, King Henry turned
against his vassal and led an army into Normandy.
But he was soundly defeated by William’s
forces and chased out of the duchy.
He tried again in 1057, and was defeated again.
This enmity continued until King Henry’s
death in 1060.
English Concerns
By 1060, William had largely taken control
of Normandy and put down internal opposition
to him.
With the death of King Henry, his 7 year old
son Phillip was named king, but was too young
to rule.
One of the regents appointed to rule the kingdom
during Phillip’s minority was William’s
father in law, Baldwin V, Count of Flanders,
so there would be no more trouble from the
crown for the time being.
So William turned his focus towards expansion.
The Duke acquired some territory on the Continent,
such as the County of Maine, and fought a
campaign in Brittany, but his keenest interest
lay to the north, across the Channel, to England.
It was becoming increasingly apparent to everyone
that King Edward the Confessor would die without
producing an heir to his throne, leaving a
power vacuum that various factions would rush
to fill.
The most logical internal candidate to succeed
Edward was Harold Godwinson, the Earl of Essex.
Harold was a leading member of the Godwin
family, the most powerful nobles in the kingdom.
He was also Edward’s brother in law.
However, Duke William also felt he had a legitimate
claim to the throne.
At one point, in 1051, the Godwins fell out
of favor with King Edward and were exiled.
It’s believed that the King reached out
to William at this point and named him his
heir: Edward had lived in Normandy for 30
years after his father was deposed by the
Danes, protected by the Dukes of Normandy,
so the connection made sense.
However, a year later, the Godwins returned
to England and reconciled with Edward, thus
leaving the question of the succession extremely
murky.
Some historical sources tell us that Harold
Godwinson traveled to Normandy around 1064,
and met with Duke William.
It’s said that he swore an oath during that
meeting to uphold William’s claim to the
throne of England.
However, the only sources that document this
are Norman, and there’s no way to know if
this actually took place or was Norman propaganda.
The Game Begins
King Edward the Confessor died January 5th,
1066.
On his deathbed, he named Harold Godwinson
as his heir.
Harold acted quickly, crowning himself king
the next day and quickly gaining the support
of the English nobility.
Across the Channel in Normandy, Duke William
was furious.
He knew at this point that the only way to
uphold his claim to the throne would be to
take it by force.
He vowed to raise an army and invade England.
This ambition was hardly secret, and all of
Europe watched and waited throughout the spring
and summer of 1066 as William prepared his
invasion force.
Harold, of course, heard of William’s plan,
and raised an army of his own to counter the
threat of a Norman invasion.
He spent most of the summer in the south of
England waiting for Duke William to make his
move.
However, most of Harold’s force was composed
of civilian militia levees that needed to
return to their fields to harvest their crops,
and the king was forced to dismiss a large
part of his army on September 8th.
And to make matters worse, around the same
time, Harold learned that another claimant
to the throne had appeared.
The Norsemen Attack
A year before the events of 1066, Harold Godwinson’s
brother Tostig had been stripped of his earldom
of Northumbria and driven into exile.
Infuriated by what he saw as his brother’s
betrayal, he went to the King of Norway, Harald
Hardrada, and convinced him to make a claim
for the English throne and invade from the
north of the country.
Harald believed he had a legitimate claim
to the throne of England because he was descended
from the line of Vikings that had conquered
and ruled England for thirty years before
Edward the Confessor took over.
Harald also spent the summer of 1066 making
preparations for his invasion, and left Norway
at the end of August with a fleet of 300 ships
and an army of 15,000 men.
He landed in England in early September, and
met up with Tostig.
Together they attacked towns and villages
throughout Northumbria, and defeated an English
army led by the local lords.
This prompted the surrender of the great city
of the north, York.
In the south, Harold learned of the Norweigan
invasion, and quickly turned north with as
many soldiers as he could muster.
He made the 185 mile trip north in only 4
days, riding day and night.
On September 25th, 1066, the Norse army left
their encampment and marched to Stamford Bridge,
where they expected to meet with representatives
of the city of York to receive hostages and
supplies.
Not expecting a fight, they left most of their
heavy armor back at the camp.
Imagine their surprise then, when they arrived
to find not cowed townspeople, but the English
royal army waiting for them.
Alarmed, Harald Hardrada and Tostig Godwinson
rode forward to meet their enemy.
King Harold approached them, alone.
He spoke to his brother, offering him his
earldom back if he turned against Hardrada
and sided with him.
Tostig asked what Harold would offer Hardrada
for his trouble.
“Seven feet of English ground, for he is
taller than other men,” Harold replied coolly.
There could be no negotiating with rival claimants
to the throne of England.
And Tostig refused to switch sides.
The Battle of Stamford Bridge was on.
The Norwegians began to retreat across the
bridge, a stronger position waiting for them
on the other side as the English attacked.
Harold’s army was held up on the bridge
by a single Norse soldier, a berserker armed
with a two handed great axe.
He killed 40 men single handedly before he
was finally killed by an English soldier who
floated under the bridge and stabbed him from
beneath.
The English rushed across the bridge, meeting
the shield wall of the Norse.
The battle was furious.
At some point, Harald Hardrada was mortally
wounded by an arrow, and Tostig Godwinson
was slain on the field.
The lack of heavy armor on the part of the
Norse made the difference, and their army
was cut to pieces.
Once the English broke through the Norse shield
wall, the battle became a slaughter.
By the time it was over, 10,000 were dead.
Harold allowed the survivors to return to
Norway peacefully.
So many had died that only 25 of the original
300 ships were needed to transport them back.
Never again would a Scandinavian army threaten
England.
The Age of the Vikings was over.
But Harold didn’t have time to celebrate
his victory.
Instead, he immediately turned around and
marched south again.
Because he knew Duke William was coming.
The Norman Invasion
Just three days after the Battle of Stamford
Bridge, on September 28th, the Norman army
landed at Pevensey Bay on the south coast
of England.
Like Harold, William didn’t know of the
Norwegian invasion, but it worked out nicely
for him because it allowed him to land unopposed.
The Duke moved his forces to the nearby town
of Hastings, where he built a wooden castle.
There he was content to wait, close to his
supply lines via the sea, for Harold to come
to him.
Harold heard of William’s invasion while
he was marching south, but proceeded more
slowly than he had when responding to the
Norwegian invasion: his army was still recovering
from the Battle of Stamford Bridge, and he
had to leave a large part of it in the north.
Even still, he probably moved TOO quickly,
had he waited a few more days, he likely would
have had more men at his disposal to face
the Normans.
As it was, Harold’s army encamped at the
top of a steep slope on the night of October
13th, a few miles north of William’s fortified
camp at Hastings.
His efforts to surprise William failed, and
the Normans knew he was coming.
The morning of October 14th dawned unusually
bright and warm for October in England.
Duke William’s Norman army left its camp
and marched to where the English were.
William hoped to settle the question of who
should rule England with a single decisive
battle.
Whoever won was clearly ordained by God to
sit on the throne, he believed.
The Battle of Hastings
The
English army was almost entirely composed
of infantry, with no cavalry and few if any
archers.
With this in mind, Harold kept his forces
on top of the hill, having his front rank
lock shields into an impenetrable wall that
would fend off the Norman infantry and cavalry
attacks, and blunt the effect of the Norman
archers.
And that’s exactly what happened during
the early stages of the battle.
Repeated charges by the Norman cavalry were
repulsed, and the Norman infantry were unable
to break through the shield wall.
The French archers were hampered by the steep
slope, firing either directly into the shield
wall, or over the heads of the English.
Then, the first decisive moment of the day:
the left flank of the Norman army suddenly
broke and ran in a panicked flight.
A rumor had spread through the ranks that
Duke William had been killed, and the Normans
wanted no part in continuing the battle without
their leader.
Even though Harold ordered his army to remain
on the hill, some disobeyed and chased the
fleeing Normans.
William was not dead, and he rode through
the ranks of the fleeing soldiers, removing
his helmet to show them that he was still
in the fight.
He managed to turn them around and attack
the pursuing English.
Outside the protection of the shield wall,
the English took heavy casualties.
A lull settled over the battlefield as the
soldiers from both armies rested.
The retreat of his left flank had given William
a new idea: if he had portions of his army
pretend to retreat, he could provoke the English
to follow, and engage them off the hill and
without the shield wall.
When the battle recommenced, it’s believed
he did this at least twice, with moderate
success.
The English were taking casualties, but the
line held.
The issue was still very much in doubt as
afternoon turned into evening.
Soon darkness would make further fighting
difficult, if not impossible.
Just as it seemed nothing would be settled
that day after all, catastrophe suddenly struck
the English.
King Harold was hit in the eye with an arrow,
going into his brain.
He fell from his horse, killed instantly.
Without their king, the English army was leaderless,
and quickly fell apart.
The Normans pursued the fleeing English for
a while, but were stopped by darkness.
It didn’t matter: the Battle of Hastings
was over, and there was only one claimant
to the English throne left standing.
King William
Despite his victory and the death of Harold,
the English still resisted the Norman invasion
for another two months, forcing William to
take the city of London by siege.
But soon enough, it was over, and on Christmas
Day 1066, William was crowned as the King
of England.
It took another five years for William to
pacify his new realm, as he dealt with a series
of rebellions by the Anglo-Saxon aristocracy.
William dealt with this by building a series
of castles throughout England, giving them
to his supporters to keep order over the land.
By the time William died, England was dotted
with over 500 castles.
The most famous fortress that William built
was the White Tower in London, which eventually
became the central keep of the Tower of London.
One of William’s key problems was his inability
to be in two places at once: when he was in
England, there were uprisings in Normandy.
And when he was in Normandy, there were rebellions
in England.
William spent most of the first ten years
of his reign travelling between the two countries,
dealing with rebels, while also gradually
transforming English life.
Over time, most of the Anglo-Saxon nobles
had been replaced by Normans, and the ones
who were left began to marry into Norman and
other French families.
Official documents were written in Latin or
French instead of Old English.
Two works enhance our modern understanding
of this period.
The first is the Bayeux Tapestry, an incredible
230 foot long piece of embroidered cloth commissioned
by William’s brother Odo shortly after the
Battle of Hastings.
The tapestry depicts the events of 1066 from
the Norman side, from King Edward’s death
to the victory of the Normans at the Battle
of Hastings.
Incredibly, this tapestry has survived intact
for over 900 years and can still be seen today
at a dedicated museum in Bayeux.
The second work was commissioned by King William
in December 1085.
He wanted a complete record of all the royal
holdings in England, a record that came to
be called “The Domesday Book”.
This book documented all the lands of the
English realm in great detail, including who
had controlled the land before the Conquest,
how much tax revenue the area produced, the
number of people who lived there, even absurdly
specific details such as how many chickens
a particular farmer had, or how much milk
a dairy farm had produced in a given year.
This record, preserved in the National Archives
in London, offers us great insight on the
disposition and administration of England
during the time of the Norman conquest.
Final Days
In 1087, William returned to Normandy to deal
with his eldest son Robert, who was allied
with the King of France in an attempt to undermine
him.
While engaged in this campaign, William was
injured by the pommel of his saddle, and the
wound grew infected.
He was taken to Rouen where his condition
quickly deteriorated.
William knew he needed to settle his affairs.
He left Robert the duchy of Normandy and his
second son William was given control of England.
Once it became clear that the king was going
to die, his advisors and courtiers all left
him to settle their own affairs.
As a result, William died completely alone
on September 9th, 1087, aged 59.
In the immediate aftermath of the king’s
death, his sons Robert, William, and Henry
all fought each other over control of the
kingdom.
Normandy itself eventually became formally
a part of the Kingdom of France, and the heritage
of the Vikings was swept away.
The course of English history, meanwhile,
was changed significantly by the events of
the Norman conquest.
Prior to the conquest, England had more closely
identified culturally with Scandinavia than
with continental Europe.
Afterwards, England was brought closer to
France, ties which bound it into the Middle
Ages and caused a centuries-long rivalry between
the two countries.
The story of the Norman conquest is one of
the most famous in world history.
It was a momentous event that shaped the course
of European history for centuries to come.
And it bestowed upon William I, King of England
and Duke of Normandy, a new title, one that
no one is likely to forget: William the Conqueror.